400 million in other Salvator Mundi
shelling here at Christie's four hundred
million dollars disappeared and the
piece is sold two years ago the painting
titled Salvator Mundi set a record as
the most expensive piece of art ever
sold at auction the image of Jesus is
one of fewer than two dozen works
attributed to Renaissance master
Leonardo da Vinci but in a new book one
author paints a different picture he
questions whether the painting is a
genuine Leonardo and if it's incredible
sale price was really the result of some
over-the-top marketing it's a most
beautiful question not the 17 painters
for more than a century art dealers
hunted for this lost treasure
the Salvator Mundi or savior of the
world an ethereal picture rumored to be
the work of an original Renaissance man
everyone wonders is the Mona Lisa's
smiling and then you stretch it out to
the Salvator Mundi and that's the most
mysterious picture he ever painted and
it's looking at us and it's saying to us
am i a Leonardo it's a mystery
art critic and author Ben Lewis tries to
solve in his new book some art
historians believe the painting is a
workshop piece done mostly by Leonardo's
assistants or that it was found in such
bad shape that it's impossible to make a
call I mean it was a poorly damaged it
had broken into five pieces it was a
huge crack down the side you can't make
any judgment about the face it's sort of
been blown away
painted in the early 1500s the Salvatore
Mundi is said to have lived for time
with Charles the first and Charles the
second only to disappear for more than
100 years until the turn of the 20th
century there's a photograph of it in
1908 which is the first time we know it
exists it's in the collection of Sir
Francis Cook and you know Christ has got
a moustache you know he's got like this
little weird hair he looks like I said a
Mexican bandit from an American 50s
movie the picture was sold in London in
1958 cataloged as one of Leonardo's
followers an American was the sole
bidder Warren [ __ ] and his wife Minnie
they'd like to buy religious art they
come to London made one on a holiday to
Europe and they decide to go to this
auction and there's a sour to a moon day
you know and it's affordable
right 1958 45 pounds why not a splurge
on vacation yeah that's about $60 I
think in American money at the time in
2005 the Salvator Mundi was auctioned in
New Orleans art dealers Robert Simon and
Alex Parrish saw potential and made the
winning bid $1,000
off and on for five years conservatory
Diane modesty knee began a painstaking
restoration first removing layers of
varnish that had been added over the
centuries each strand almost seems to be
individually portrayed as the light hits
it Robert simon says for years he didn't
believe the painting was a true Leonardo
not until traces of an earlier
composition were discovered the painting
has a figure of Christ was a blessing
hand as the cleaning was resolved it was
clear that the thumb is in two positions
one had been corrected by the artist
because of all the copies of the
painting it's in the second position try
to think of all the possibilities of
what could account for all the evidence
pointed to the fact that it was a change
by the artist in 2008 a group of experts
agreed with Simon the piece was indeed
by Leonardo da Vinci
Simon Says this never-before-seen
ultraviolet image reveals that most of
the original paint is there the darker
areas like on the face body and
background are what have been restored
Diane and the Dean of Robert Simon
decided okay it's authenticated as a
Leonardo great now let's make it live
again mm-hmm and they added in you know
they say we still only did the minimum
but what did you find as to why they
would want to make it live again it
would be impossible to achieve the
highest possible price for this Leonardo
without giving it a thorough market
restoration the paintings sold to a
Swiss art dealer in 2013 for 80 million
dollars financially there was a gain for
you so I guess it would be better for
you to have this Bibi Salvator Mundi and
have this belief and have it restored to
the greatest value right the goal our
goal all along was for it to be in a
museum
I think that the things that were done
quite ethically are being presented as
if there was some something that was
dirty or nefarious or that information
was being withheld I find that insulting
I have 10 million
Leonardo or not 160 is fit in five years
time the Salvator Mundi skyrocketed in
value so in 2017 it became the most
expensive piece of art ever sold it's
believed to have been purchased on
behalf of Saudi Arabia's de facto ruler
Crown Prince Mohammed bin Salman the
price tag 400 million dollars plus 50
million in fees you know how do you turn
a thousand bucks into four hundred and
fifty million bucks
you can only do that today with art
Geist has a sort of mysterious slightly
feminine air it has that sort of Mona
Lisa ambiguity and that's part of the
whole marketing of the picture away I
think that's what really interested you
know the Saudi buyer is that they could
own the male Mona Lisa and if they put
it you know in their museum you know
their museum would become a destination
the Salvator Mundi hasn't been seen by
the public
since the Christie's Auction its present
whereabouts somewhat of a mystery just
like the paintings past and for some
still even its beginning admit to you
that on different days I changed my mind
sometimes I look at it and I just think
like there's something so weird about
the face in this picture there's
something modern about it how could
somebody how could somebody come up with
such an original face only Leonardo
would think out of the box like that and
you know moments like that I think maybe
now a couple things to point out Robert
Simon who we interviewed in the piece
who originally found it paid the
thousand dollars he has his own book
coming out about this restoration
process and as for the whereabouts this
is the mystery that remains it was
supposed to be displayed at the Louvre
in Abu Dhabi back in September 2018
mysteriously did not happen people are
wondering where it is the Louvre in
Paris has an exhibition about Leonardo
in the fall and they are hoping to have
the painting fingers crossed fascinating
yeah actually is a job and when you
thank you when you look at the work and
all of the history of this picture it
really is it's a pretty picture and then
hold on a second four hundred million
dollars for the picture and fifty
million fees person you want all the
marketing marketing